Hello everybody, my na- oooooh...
(Go Tell Aunt Rhody starts)
Go Tell Aunt Rhody
Go Tell Aunt Rhoooooody
*Mark becomes deeply disturbed*
Mark: What?
Singing Lady: That everybody's....
Spooky Lady Voice: Deeeaaaddddd
Well, I didn't see that the first time that I played this game,
Whaaeeere did that come from??
No, look- I didn't see this menu!
I didn't see any of this the first time I came into this game,
it was just a black screen.
What the hell was that intro??
I guess that's cool, it kinda left out some spoilers.
Anyway,
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier.
and welcome back to Resident Evil 7.
we're continuing out adventure, where we are in the thick of the family!
And I don't know if that's a good way to say that,
but that's exactly our situation.
Now can I start this goddamn game?
Alright, so we're back into this- oh main house map.
That's probably useful...
so there was a guest house,
and now I'm in the main house.
And I'm in the laundry room of the main house
and- OH is that the item box?
Ooh, I got to escape from the house. I don't know how I'm going to do that,
but I need to get a key over there.
There was some kind of crest in the door,
so I'm under the assumption that that's what I'm going to need
to be able to get out of here.
At least that is usually how it goes-
Who is squeak-squonking?
Recreation room, GRANDMA'S ROOM?!
Which I don't know if I wanna go into Grandma's room.
But I'm good I was- I'm glad I was correct on the name of grandma over there.
So I generally know where all this is.
I don't need to be here,
I could get to the garage,
but I also need to get to the main hall.
So there is two places I could go,
I could go to the garage or I could go upstairs.
If I find a way out of the, uh-
oh no, I'd have to go to the main hall to be able to that.
Oh that's not going to work out for me...
Alright, either way I think the only place to go is the garage.
I don't know how to get there but I'm going to see what's in the
item box over here.
oh- HELLO?
ZOE?
Zoey 101, can anybody help me? HELLO?
Oh shit, I am alone.
Alright, that-
THAT'S good enough.
I should remind myself that I'm NOT exactly alone.
I've got so many family members.
New items have been added: supply box and defense coin
I don't know what the hell- hah - what is a defense coin gonna do for me?
Ooh shit...Okay...
I- I only have a limited number of inventory space so
I'm assuming I don't need the driver's license and the email from Mia
I could get the supply box. *reading the description of said supply box*
So I'm gonna take that
Gimme that, yeah.
These coins are said to have special effects on those who carry them. This one was made to toughen your body.
How in the hell does that work?!
WHAT?!
I'm gonnna get a- this, this is the beatin coin. You know when PaPa wants to smack me with his shovel
It's gonna make my rump a bit sturdier than it was before.
I'll take it I guess.. Alright
I need to find my gun again.  I got my stanky danky kush and my ancient coin,
which is only old and  commemorative which isn't going to help my ass with the beatings.
An-and I guess that's all gonna be good.
And I am assuming that those are unified across all the game
So I'ma be able to see whatever I need
They really stink.
Then why did I look at them?!
I appreciate the detail in the environment but I need to have a bit more common sense than to stick my nose into that
Okay what do we got here?
Oh boy! More-- more slanky wanky kush!
Tab to combine inventory. Ooh.
Chem fluid, a liquid that can be combined to make items. Can't be used as is
Ohhh!
Oh shit! That's how I make my goop juice!
Ohh!!!
I gotta take my slanky blanky kush and mix it with chem fluid and somehow
that's gonna magically repair all the holes in my hands. Just splash that goop juice on me!
Okay enough being in this room
Where I'm safe and alone and I'm gonna save one more time just because I'm a coward.
No, I'm a BRAVE BOY!
I'm a brave boy and I'm gonna brave the dangers in this house
Alright.
So I guess I just need to-
You unlocked it. Well that's good
*Phone ringing*
Sorry.
*Phone rings again*
Is there any where I could cl-- okay alright there we go
Okay. Hello?! Zoe!? Is that you?! Is that you, Zoe?!
Friend?!
Zoe: You did good, Ethan.
Mark: Thanks!
Ethan: Zoe, right?
Mark: I almost died!
Ethan: What the fuck are these-
Zoe: Shut up and listen if you wanna stay alive
Mark: Ok thanks *imitates Zoe* "alive"
Zoe: You gotta get out of that house
There might be a way out through the main hall.
Ethan: Alright.
Zoe: Oh,
And that thing on your wrist is a codex.
Don't lose it. It's important.
*Zoe hangs up*
I don't-- I don't remember you having an accent before, Zoe.
And now that I vaguely remember, I distinctly--
Ethan: Hell of a girl.
Hell of a girl yeah whoa whoa wow whoa
Wowie whoa WHOA
That's a hell of a girl. But I distinctly remember in the cut scene where someone was stapling my hand back on
It might have been a Zoe-type character that was doing it because that voice sounded a little bit familiar.
It wasn't quite MaMa quality.
We shall see about that. so--
Hopefully everybody is out for dinner.
*Door squeaks closed*
Yeeesh.
And maybe grandma has retired back to her room.
And isn't going to be bothering anybody, but this is open now.
Okay.
Oh, good, yes! He's-- he's-- he's customized it.
Ooh boy...
Wait, what?
Ohh, I need a lock pick for that.  So eventually I've gotta be able to find a lockpick.
I'm assuming that maybe I'm gonna make my way down to the-- to the guest house
It looks fragile. Maybe you can break it with something
MY BARE HANDS?!
My-my-my fisticuffs?
My-my-my-my
Daddy stranglers? That's not good.
Garage. Oh, thanks, I can read
Alright, lets make our way in here.
Well this looks maniacal.
I don't know why everything needs to be locked away.
It's secured with tape that can't be removed by hand
Why?! If I grab the tape with my bad, stapled hand is it just gonna fall right off?!
How can that not be removed by hand?!
How strong could it possibly be? Bunch of bullshit. Okay, alright, I'll play your game! You rogue!
So there's gotta be a way to break that box.  I've gotta be able to find an axe or some other useful type of item here somewhere
Yeeesh
Still night.  I have a funny feeling it's going to be perpetually night the entire time I'm here.
But I've gotta be able to find like an item with which to swing-swong.
Nothing there.
*knock, knock knock*
Hi
*the knocks repeat*
Person: Hey.
Mark: Oh, hi! Hello! Hi!
Maybe I shouldn't come to the door? But I'm--
I'ma do it anyway.
Hello.
Person: Open up!
Mark: Oh, I will open up because that seems like the right thing to do.
Hello.
Hi.
How you doing?
Ethan: Hey you gotta help me!
Policeman: Hold on, back up.
Mark: Okay.
Policeman: Now, sir, do you live here? I mean, is this your property?
Mark: Nooo!
Ethan: What? Me? No, no!
Policeman: Alright. Now we got several calls about some missing persons lately
Ethan: You don't undestand. I gotta get outta here!
Policeman: Now calm down.
Mark: Yeah, explain yourself.
Ethan: You're not listening to me!
There are crazy people in this house trying to fucking kill me!
Policeman: Well alright, lemme tell you this.
You don't exactly seem like you're playing with a full deck yourself, alright?
Ethan: Are you kidding me?!
Mark: Jeez
Policeman: Look, like I said, we've had several missing persons calls,
and I can't rule out that an outsider like yourself may not be involved.
Mark: Oh, wow.
Ethan: Alright. I'll tell you whatever you want.
Policeman: Alright. Now that's more like it. Now, meet me in the garage. We'll talk there.
Mark: H-how are you-
Ethan: Hey, wait! You gotta give me your gun!
Mark: Whoa.
Policeman: You must have lost your mind.
Ethan: Look, officer-
Policeman: Deputy.
Ethan: Right, deputy. Now do you wanna see my name in the obituaries,
or do you wanna be a hero and save my life?
Ethan: A fucking pocket knife?
Deputy: Here. Take it! That's all you're gonna get.
Now, go. Garage. Now.
Mark: Yeah, you weren't- Ethan, come on, man,
you weren't making a strong case for yourself.
Ethan: What am I gonna do with a knife?
Mark: Well, I mean, you're gonna STAB someone with it.
You might stab a box or two.
Is that Big Box Barry needs to be stabbed?
HA HA!
He haa~
Okay, anyway got that.
some ammo- God, who goes up to a cop and asks them for their GUN?!
That is, like, the number one suspicious thing that you could possibly do!
th- he-heyah!
I couldn't do this with my bare hands.
Oh, that was ridiculously easy.
Okay, alright then.
Alright, I see this, okay, alright, ok,
you know- Ooh hi.
Oh...
So you're, like, a legit cop,
and you might actually be able to help me.
I should put my knife away.
There we go, very relaxed.
Ethan: Hey! We gotta get the fuck outta here.
Deputy: Now, first you need to tell me what you're doing out here alone in the middle of the night.
Ethan: Me? What about you?
Deputy: Now, it's my job. Why don't you do YOUR job and tell me?!
Answer my questions!
Ethan: You're not gonna believe me if I told you.
Deputy: Try me.
Deputy: Hey. Put that door back up. Put that door back up!
Ethan: Wait! Wait!
Mark: WHAT THE FUCKING FUUUUCK?!
OH!
Jack: Fuck it. I'm gonna kill every one of you.
Mark: Maybe you shouldn't- OH JESUS OH GOD!!!
heyeyaAHEHYEAH-A-E-I-O-U
What the fucking fuck happened?!
Jeezums!
Okay, I'm gonna get my knife out now.
Hey, hey, hey, hey!
You wanna be nice about this?
Don't make me bust out my daddy stranglers!
he he ha HA!
Oh shit, okay, alright. I gotta get the gun somehow
Oh, you're gonna come around that way?
Jack: You're part of the family now.
Mark: No, I'm not part of no family!
I'm not part of no family, I'm not part of your family
I'm not part of YOUR family
*Nervous laughter x 2*
I got ya!
Oh, I got your number now!
Whoa boy.
Whoa boy!
WHoa boy...
whOAA!
WOW BOY! Oh boyyo!
Ow, fucko!
If i can get him in the head to stun him enough,
he might...
not
cut me in half.
Oh shit, two bullets...
Fuck- AAAh miss both of 'em OW
Why?! Jeesums!
Owhohohoho
Jack: What's the matter, son? You out of ammo?
MarK: Yeah a little bit  Y-Yeah a little bit
Oh, shit.
Well, what am i gonna do about this? I got GOOP JUICE.
*makes goopy healing noise*
THAT FELT GOOD!
OKAY, I HOPE I GOT MORE OF THAT!!
IMMA STAB YA!
Oh fuck, OW! Mah nose!
Agh!
*laughing* Oh I didn't guard, whoopsies.
Ok.
Alright, bring it on!
I'm out of GOOP JUICE, but I'm gonna make Goop Juice out of your BLOOD.
I... fuck, hang on.
Yeah yeah
Jack: I'm an old man, son. You can't take an old man?
Mark: Woah oww!
Yeah, I probably can't, ya know.
Yeah this ain't gonna look-- this ain't lookin good to me.
Aw, man. No, no! No, no, don't do it!
Yeah yeah, yeah, yeah!
Jack: You kill me, and I just come right on back.
Mark: Is that how that works? AW, COME ON MAN! AW, NO!
That was my good arm! Actually it was my bad arm, but..
Ow.
Jack: I don't know what she ever saw in you.
Mark: Well, apparently not much.
I is dead! Well, that did not go well for me.
Let's try that again.  That guy was tough. What I was I supposed to do?
*reading the tip on screen*
OH! You mean what I was doing BEFORE,
but then I STOPPED doing it in the last episode because I thought it wouldn't do me any good?!
Calm down now! Whoooa. Hey, calm down now!
Ooh, what is this? Car key? Okay, I'll take that.
Yoom!
Ohhh, what's that? You got shot in the face? I don't feel too bad!
Ey ey eye eye!
Shomp shomp oh shit shomp
Aha! Okay, so do I get in the car or somethin?
Is that what I do?
Jack: Every day it's the same thing...
Mark: You don't know that.
Also, nice hole in your face.
Oh ey uh okay
I'm gettin in! I'M GETTIN IN! I'M GETTIN IN!! I'M GETTIN OUTTA HERE, BABY!!!
There's no way hes gonna sto- Ohh hey, fuck off!
Jack: Oh no you don't. I'M driving!
Mark: Oh, okay, alright then if you wanna drive so badly.
Goodness gracious. Whoa, hey! Whoa! Whoa! Whoa!
Nice convertible, dude!
Okay
Jack: You better start runnin', boy!
Mark: Uhh... I don't know how this is going to work out... Okay good bye!
Jeez! Hehehehehehe
Alright. A little joy ride never hurt anybody.
Some GTA physics going on in here.
Ha vroom! Oh, shit.
Vroom? Vroom vroom vroom?
Hahahahaha hahahaha haaa, shit.
That's funny. That's actually really funny.
Ahh Tokyo Drift up in this garage!
Oh shit.
Can I just shoot him?
Oww, fuck, goddamn it! That didn't hit me
What an asshole!
Okay, I guess that's not gonna do any good. Whoa.
Jack: I'm gonna get ya! I'm gonna get ya!
Mark: *imitating him* Hehe I'm gonna getcha!
Ohhh ye no ya not! Oh shit.
Oh, fuck.
Alright then. Whoa, jeezums!
You feelin okay, buddy?
Are you-- are you sober enough to-- wow, fucking goddamn it.
Alright.  Blooo bloo let me splash some goop juice on my car wounds
Eeeyeyeyeye aw, fucking goddamn it!
This asshole!
I'm outta goop juice.  I gotta move!
Fucking hell! Whoa.
Shit, dude.
How much more does this guy need to take? Ohh, fuck.
Maybe if I just slash him up.
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, whoa!
Whoa- fucking- whoa.
Can you be dead now? Can you be dead? Can you be dead please? Can you please be dead? Whoa!
Whoa, whoa FUCK!
OH, FUCK! OH, I'M SORRY!
OH, HI!
Jack: Oh boy-
Mark: Okay, are you gonna stay down?
Oh, fuck,
Are you gonna stay down? You're gonna stay down?
Oh he's not gonna st--  AHH fucking fuck! Holy shit!
Okay, then.. Are you gonna stay down this time?
You gonna fucking stay down, boy-o?
God, you are hard as shit to kill. And I have a funny feeling you're not killed yet!
You killed?
He did say something about if I kill him, he'll just keep coming back
So I think that leds-- lends some credence to
My theory that these guys are effectively immortal, they do keep coming back.
Excuse me whil.e I mix this with my stanky dank
Habooski, alright. so I got that
And then also he said something when he killed me the first time, he said
"I don't know what SHE sees in you"
So they all must follow and get their abilities from some originator girl
I imagine it's like this creepy girl figure or whatever or something to do with the normal viruses.
Because I don't know if this has to do with the uroboros virus, which is
What a... What plagued people in Resident Evil 4
I believe 5&6. Aw, I can't go up there? It looks like I can go up there!
Aw, come on now! That looks like I can go up there!
Oh, there we go. Okay.
HEY! FUCKING GODDAMN IT!
Jack: Do I have your attention, boy?
You are about to see something wonderful.
*Gunshot*
Ethan: Fuck!
Mark: *whispers* What the fuck?
He's still moving...
Holy shit, he's still moving..
Or he was.
Good God.
Uughh.
Alright then! That was something wonderful indeed! I'm really happy that I saw that.
Is your car gonna come back to life too? Alright then.
Ey boy.. I'm just gonna go up here and try to... forget.. m-my own insanity and hopefully get past this in some other way.
Oh, look! It's a crest!
I can take this. Oh boy.
So if I put this on the door, I'll be able to go to the main hall and then continue this... horrifying...adventure.
Okay, so I got the ox statue that I'll combine with the whatever the hell I was doing bef-- whoooaa, kay
Oh...oh, alright...
I guess this would have been intelligent to maybe come up here while the guy was driving around, maybe I could've saved myself some trouble
But then again, I'm just a brave boy. I never said I was a SMART boy. I'm just brave.
And stupid... Alright, let me get in here and save
Now that I'm out of this insanity here.
Okay, so...
Ugh.
So the only person that can help me, the police officer, is now dead and I don't know if he had time to radio for backup.
Now it's going to be a whole lotta people missing for the small backwater police department that they HAVE.
And the father properly introduced himself and introduced his powers. And I need to splash some goop juice on me
Haaaablblblblb
Clean it up on my face real good.
Ahhh, I feel all sorts of better.
Do I feel all sorts of better?
Ahh, not quite 100% just yet, but maybe I will soon.
But at least I got a gun and a knife, which means I can do a lot more
than I was able to do before.
Okay, but now that I got the ox statue, I can go right to the main hall.
And hope for the BEST when it comes to my survival.
But then again I'm not-- I'm not-- I'm not terribly confident about this, considering
the father just shot himself in the face and was still moving when he was on the ground.
Ugh, man.
It reminds me of this flash game that I played a long time ago.
Umm.. It was about the end of the world.  A more biblical sense of the end of the world,
But it was when-- The game was about you in this apocalypse scenario
But the-- the tragedy of it was-- wooo hey.
Alright then.. Very fancy. Like it a lot. Can I just push now?
Ooh I can!
*Creepy music*
Oh that's a fan. Oooo
Oh, fuck, dude.
Okay, I'm a brave boy!
I'm a BRAVE BOY! OH BOY!
Oh hi.. "Shoot me! Shoot me!" I don't think I want to.
Maybe I was supposed to shoot it and not swing-swong at it?! Okay..
Alright then, there was another one over here. Ooo that looks like a person
But anyway, the game was about an apocalypse scenario and it was literally the end of the world
And everyone that was left on earth
*Glass shattering*
literally couldn't die.
And it wasn't in the sense that if they got shot they wouldn't die-
No matter how small the piece of them was left after they were dead, no matter what happened to them,
they were still alive. If they were a writhing pile of flesh,
they were still alive.
Now, now in this world they seem to be healing, which probably a little bit better than the other way.
But I cannot imagine *phone rings* what it would be like to just be like
being shot a million times and still being alive and feeling.. that horrifying pain.
Hello, Zoe.
Zoe: Did my daddy give you a hard time?
Mark: Ohhh.
Ethan: That's your father?
Zoe: He used to be.
Mark: Mmmmh
Ethan: I'm sorry... but he's, uh, he's dead now.
MarK: No, don't you get it!
Zoe: You just might be able to pull this off.
Mark: Ughhh
Ethan: What? Pull what off?
Zoe: There's something I need you to do, but I can't explain it right now.
Mark: Hmm
Zoe: You may need some sort of keys to do it, but find a way out of the house.
Mark: Okay.
Zoe: I'll be in touch. *hangs up*
Mark: Mmmmkay.
I mean I could just.. ya know...
Jump through one of these windows I'm-- I'm totally fine!
If theres g- oh my God, that door is amazing!
But if I just get some glass shards in my eyeballs as I jump through a window,
I think I'll just splash some goop juice on them and then I'll be fine!
Or maybe I won't be.
But that's fascinating 'cause according to the map
or the little poster in the...
Eughh...
*It doesn't fit this lock*
According to the map
that I found in the basement right before I found Mia,
there are three children.
There is a son and daughter and then someone that might be saying
"I'm sorry, I won't be bad anymore."
Whatever they did say.
"Over 20 Missing in 2 Years" Captain Howell from state
police told reporters they have started a search for Helen Midkiff,
a college student from North Carolina who was travelling in Luisiana.
Ms. Midkiff hasn't been heard of since the night of the twenty-first.
Reports of missing persons in South Louisiana have increased dramaticaly in the past two years.
The majority of these missing are tourists and vagrants. At least 20 people are thought to have gone missing so far.
Police suspect foul play and believe there may be a connection
between the incidents. Plans are in place to step up local
interrogations and increase personnel to increase- errr further the investigations.
Alyssa Ashcroft, January 19, 2016
I don't know why that name remin-
rings a bell or anything, but I'm not a 100% sure
that that is not coincidental of who that is.
OK, what are we looking at here?
OK. Why are we looking at that?
OH!
I know what I need to do.
I need to cast a shadow.
OH! COOL!
Well I mean that's not the right thing,
but I mean I could - I could try something.
So I need to find something that casts the shadow of a bird.
Something that may not at its
... surface...
look like it might be a bird.
Could it be? My sweet fragrant herbs?
Mnhm, nooo, that doesn't work correctly.
Ok.
So nothing about that works,
but I need to find an item and then
put it there for the shadows to go play.
But right now I need to find my way through
the rest of this place before I die
a horrible, horrible death.
I have more chem fluid though,
which means that I can combine that with that.
Oooh!
Gunpowder and chem fluid?!
How do you combine chem fluid with anything
to be able to get what you need?!
I'm all about game logic here,
so Imma ignore that
'n just carry on with the game without criticizing too much.
This is all fascinating,
because like I said I don't know if this has to do
with the Uroboros Virus.
It seems to be more
catered towards some type of curse.
Something more spiritual than
was in the last games, but
I-I-I'm pretty sure it ties in,
because it wouldn't be "Resident Evil"
and also called "Biohazard"
if there wasn't some kind of biological component
to all of this.
Is this the daughter?
"Eveline, May 2, 2014"
No, that wouldn't be the daughter, then,
Zoe seems to be older than that.
No, I believe there's a son and a daughter
and then a third child and that is probably the one-
Ooooooooh Hi, Grandma!
HI!
I didn't seeeee you there.
How you doing? You alright? You alright?
Don't worry. I'm gonna be a brave boy for you.
Ooohhh boi. Okay,
see ya see ya hmhm *smooch*
Smooches!
Oh wait am I...
am I getting near your room?
Oh boy, I hope not.
*thunk*
Ooh boy.
Okay, I thought you left for a second there, grandma,
I would have been devastated if you were gooone.
I would also be ecstatic if you were gone.
Oh boy.
*intense inhaling*
Oohhohoh boy, *more inhaling*
that's an ominous hallway.
*whispers* what the fuck...
Oh hi.
Hi! Hello!
Marguerite, you're looking good!
sorry about killing your husband,
but i'm pretty sure he's gonna be back. :/
Okay, so imma look at the -
fuuhuckin hell-
the wind is just... asinine.
Okay, so I need- I need to keep going through,
but i'm getting dangerously close to-
*loud stomp*
Ooookay, how about noot.
Okay.
"Maybe it's daddy's hobby"
So is that- is that just what I'm gonna call him from now on?
I'm gonna call him Daddy,
so long as everyone's okay with us calling this guy Daddy,
I'm gonna call him Daddy.
So Daddy and Mama
and then brobro,
and then sister-Zo-Zo-
Zoey-Zoey.
I don't know which one is more ominous to go down,
but I'm gonna go down this way first.
Oohhh, that's grandma's room 2x
Oh that is- *noise*
that is 100% grandm'as room.
Ooh, I don't know if I wanna go in there, but I'm gonna give it a go.
I'm gonna give it a gander.
Whoa boy.
Hello? Ah, this looks almost inviting.
Oh boy, what do we got here?
Marguerite, move that piece-of-shit hippy we caught
from the hall to the processing area.
Okay! What a loving family!
What the fuck?
"Looks like the familiy stuffed it themselves"
Oh, good!
Why in the heck did I pick this up?
Did this have anything to do with the pants-flesh statue outside?
Whatever.
So, I got this shit,
break that shit, whatever good that's gonna do me.
Okay.
Whoa, there's a shotgun in the other room!
I could definitely use that, but I don't have a scorpion key.
So I need to find some sort of universal key,
because there's been about 3 other doors that I've seen so far
that have had a scorpion pattern to them
Oooohhh, and there's another VHS tape!
"Mia"?
Oh, no.
Oh, no, this is not gonna be good.
Oh, this is gonna be less than good.
Oohh, I don't know what this is gonna be,
but i have a bad feeling about it.
*reads the tape's title*
Oh, is this the video that she was recording in the beginning of the game?
Oh, shit.
No, it's different.
Mia: Ethan, if you find this-
I know I can't expect anything from you.
Not after what happened. After what I did.
Mark: *whispers* what did you do?
Mia: But I just want you to know that wasn't me.
I don't- I don't know what happened.
There's so much that you need to know.
Marguerite: There you are!
You gave us quite a scare, young lady!
Mark: Oh am I playing?
I'm gonna be playing now?
I think I'm gonna be playing now.
Ooooh, shit.
I am gonna be playing now!
Oh my God!
Mia: I can't let her catch me again.
Mark: No, I can't!
Hi, Marguerite.
HI MARGUERITE
Okay, I'm gonna go now,
can't let her catch me again.
So what did she do? (she stabbed us!)
This isn't right now, obviously,
this is not right now.
Ugh, oh my God.
This is obviously recorded in the past,
so she must have done something to betray Ethan's trust. (like stabbing him)
Now my default assumption is cheating,
which could entirely be possible,
or leaving him.
What a gentle rejection,
I was just trying to go in there!
OH, my God,
whatthefffucki-
Girl's voice: Over here, Mommy!
Mark: What
the
fuck?
What
the
fuck?
Oh.
The fuck..?
Okay.
Alright, okay.
Ah, fuck.
I'm a brave girl.
I'M A BRAVE GIRL!!!
UUGHGH I'M A BRAVE GIRL!!!
oh what is with all the GOOP?!
Ugh, fuck. Goddammit.
Fuck the goop.
Ah, I don't wanna fuck the goop. Don't fuck the goop.
Do anything BUT fuck the goop.
Don't fuck that goop.
Marguerite: I am sick and tired over being sick and tired of your bullshit, girl.
Mark: oh oh
Mia: I need to hide... I need to hide...
Mark: This is as good as spot as any-
Marguerite: Why are you putting me through this?
MarK: I don't know Marguerite!
Marguerite: What have I done to deserve this except open my home and feed you?
*middle finger self-defense rises from the ashes*
Mark: Khhyaa
Marguerite: I don't understand you at all. This is a gift.
Mark: Oh, okay. Yeah, a gift.
The gift of immortality, I suppose.
The gift of fucking weirdness.
Ughh... alrighty then.
Carrying on!
So there was that little girl tho,
that definitely did occur,
and I don't know if in this flashback there would be equivalent secrets to anything that I've seen before.
Marguerite: This house- this house has seen more than you can imagine, and it knows.
Mark: Oooh, that's definitely the eagle thing. That's the eagle thing that I need.
I need to find that, but I can't pick it up.
Marguerite: You just don't understand or is it that you just don't care?
Mark: I- I don't know which is which. I can't seem to move anywhere.
AAaHhH i'm going in the bayou.
No I'm not.
*grumpy Mark*
Marguerite: I know you and Zoe are plotting.
Mark: No we're not.
Marguerite: I know you are scheming.
Mark: No, not at all- you don't know nothin'
Marguerite: You think I don't know what you want to do with that boy Ethan?
Mark: Marry him, maybe?
Maybe I'm already am married to him, maybe?
I don't know what you're talking about, Ethan
Wait, so does that mean Mia and Zoey were plotting about Ethan
before they even called me out here?
Maybe they did. Maybe they wanted me here for a reason.
Maybe they wanted me here to help or maybe they wanted me here to-
whoa
I thought she was gone, okay.
Marguerite: No... no no, don't come over here.
Mark: Yeah, don't do that! You don't need to do that!
That's the opposite of what you need to do!
Hello. Hi, hi Mama.
Eeegh
What are you doing? 2X
Why are you doing it?
I don't understand what is going on!
What- do I need to get-
Marguerite: I'll feed you to my babies and fertilize the garden with what was left.
Mark: That sounds horrible.
Why would you say things like that?
Are you done?
You done?
Marguerite: We open our home!
Mark: Little bit.
Marguerite: We open our hearts!
Mark: Eh, I don't know if you have hearts.
Marguerite: And what do you do?
Mark: I have no idea, tell us.
What do we do?
Wwwhat do we do?
What...?
So she's definitely gone now.
Yes. No. Maybe so.
Ooh.
Yeah, I think she's definitely gone.
Okay, so let me just- *pause*
just double-check around here to make sure there's nothing that I need.
She's not coming back, is she? Why would she?
Okay.
Ahh.
Oh.
I don't know- ooh, it does!
Holy shit!
This is a lesson! How 'bout that?
Ohh pretty close, huh? Nice.
Ugh. Again, don't know how that black magic works. but okay.
I'll trust that. That's perfectly normal and
standard behaviour for anything in a normal cursed house with a cursed family that can never die.
Where am I going?
Ooh, shit.
Oh, God. I gotta shimmy through here.
oohHH LITTLE PIGGY
UUGGHGH LITTLE PIGGY
Ohh fuck, little piggy. Maybe I shouldn't be SHOUTING
IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS CLOSED ENVIRONMENT!!!
I'M A BRAVE BOY!!!
Uggh fuck, dude.
Okay, alright. I guess nothing bad happened
Yeeesh.
Which seems the total opposite of whatever goes on when you go on one of those things
Okay, this is where the little girl was,
so maybe she left something behind,
because usually when someone appears from the across of a-
Marguerite: She loves you. She wants us to be a family, God dammit.
Mark: Oh oh. Oh fuck, oh, fuck. I- t- the- Where the fuck am I gonna hide?!
Marguerite: You... you!
Mark: Fuuck.
Marguerite: All you have to do is accept her fucking gift!
Mark: I don't wanna do that. I really don't wanna do that.
And why did she call me "Mama?"
Why didn't she call you "Mama", Mama?
So you have to accept her gift to fully become welcomed into the family, as far as I know,
and then become immortal, or whatever it is.
Marguerite: We love you... why can't you see that?!
Mark: Oh fuck, oh fuck. Eegh
Marguerite: Embrace us!
Mark: No-oh God. Ooh jeez.
Oh jeez, oh boy.
Marguerite: There are known unknowns here, and you are not paying fucking attention.
Mark: Okay, alright
Marguerite: No, no, no, no, no - you don't fuckin' try to escape your share of the blame.
Mark: YEEGH!
Marguerite: There's no way out of here, missy.
Mark: Okay SOORRY!
I didn't know there was no way out of here. I didn't mean it!
Oh, fuck.
looks like it's part of something and then i get closed off
Oh fuck.
Oh no.
Oh, hello. Who's this?
Okay, that's Eveline. I know that from the smaller photograph. That's Eveline.
Egh, don't jumpscare me, please.
ahhhHaHAhhAHEEY FUCKING HI
Marguerite: Where do you think you're going?
Mark: I don't know at all.
Oh fuck, hi, oh shit.
Yeah, take that. What do you think of that?
Mia: Ethan! Ethan, please help me!
Mark: Okaaay.
Mia: Help, Ethan! No!
Mark: Alright.
okay!
Sure, I'll do that! Okay...
So... but the main tak away from this is that she intentionally made that video
OBVIOUSLY that video is, you know, story telling. It's supposed to advance the story,
but she made the video for a reason cause she was trying to prove a point.
She's been living in this place for a while. She knows where to go.
She's just trying to hide from them-
Ethan: What did they do to you, Mia?
Mark: -and then maybe show Ethan something
So there was something in there, obviously game-mechanic wise, to show Ethan about the
shit that they were doing with the shadows, but
other than that, I feel like there was something more to that.
Whoa... hello.
"Blue Dog's Head"? Well that's awfully convenient.
I don't know what I'm gonna do with that, but i'll take it.
Okay, so I got a blue dog's head, which is nice, I s'pose.
What do we do with that?
M'kay.
"October 2nd. Reports say a storm's coming."
"I had a lot of trouble cleaning up after the last one a few years back."
"I guess it's time to reinforce the windows and shore up the roof. Maybe I'll get Lucas to help."
So is Lucas the guy?
"The water has finally receded. The house is alright, but the old house is badly damaged."
"Lucas is making a fuss about a huge ship that's washed up in the bayou."
"If that's true, I better report it to the parish. I'll go check it out tomorrow."
Who wrote this journal?
Is this Daddy? Did Daddy write this journal?
I have no idea.
I don't know what Daddy does.
I don't know what Daddy does in his spare time besides blowing his own face off,
willy-nilly,
but I guess we can just carry on now.
I don't think there's anything left here, and I can't get in grandma's room.
Wait, did i go in here? I don't think I did.
Helloo?
Oh, shi- fuck.
Oh, hi. helloo. Who are you?
Who are you?
Who are you...
Ooh, more herb, good.
M'kay... *sound of water drop*
That's probably okay.
What the fuck does that say?
I can't tell what that says.
Probably *another drop* not too important.
I didn't' even notice the flickering lights over here. Hello?
Ahhh oh, good.
A BATHROOM.
NOTHING BAD EVER HAPPENED IN A HORROR GAME IN THE FUCking bathroom whatthefuck is-
uuUgGhGHG
UUUGHGHUGH
I don't have enough space!
I don't know if I want enough space!
ooH OH GOD
Who took a bath in here?!
Was this grandma shedding off her skin?!
*disgusted noise*
Okay... man, that's- that's gotta suck for grandma.
You know you're immortal, but you're stuck in your old bod.y
Man, I don't have enough space for this.
I don't even have any "chem,"
so i've gotta- i've got a few things that i can put away
in the miscelanious storage containers
i've got like this supply box. can i open this?
wait yeah, what's in this?
oohh, i need to open the supply box
well, that probably'd be useful. so i'm gonna come back for that
i think i can get downstairs to the
to the item box to be able to deposit somethings and also save cause that's marginally important
but also, you know, to get my stuff organized cause i'm getting a lil-
grandma!
hi, you're still there
ooooo
don't worry grandma, i didnt' go see your private shotgun collection
i didn't see all of your knick knacks and paddy whacks
don't worry, you're all good there
was this door open the whole time?
wow
can i have that? i don't have enough space for that
i'm gonna come back for that, once i empty out my stuff and see what's in the supply box
probably just more stanky-dank
and a little more chem to make bullets out it, for some reason
okay, how bout that one
"You can't use that." why can't i use that there?
why can't i use that there? it's very obvious that i can use that there
what about a commemorative dog's head?
okay, apparently can't use that there anyway. alright so
i'm just gonna open the supply box then, see what's in here
an empty box that contains something to help you along the way and sTrONg first-aid med
what do i do with the strong shit
do i just dump it on my head or do i squeeze it up my butt
... i don't know which would be better at this point ...
okaay, so i've sorted out my bullshit inventory, that's enough waste of time
i go get going there cause there's a gun with my name on it
and then i got a pendulum that doesn't fit in the other clock
and i've got a dog's head that i don't know what the fuck to do with
but i think it has something to do with another- another type of lock like this one here
it doesn't go on the other side because this door is obviously already opened
but there's a gun, right over here and i know it's gonna get complicated
if i have to constantly change out the ammo for gun
ooOhHH THAT WAS A MISTAKE I'M SORRY
ooo
uh oh
ohhhh
i get it
ooohhhh that's a lot of inventory you're spacing out
that's a girsty ass gun
ohh
so what if- i just need to replace it with something of equal weight to be able to do what i need to do
the word "Living room" is written on this clock, maybe i could use that
it doesn't fit
there was another gun in grandma's room
but i don't know if that's what i need to do
so i'm gonna put this back for now until i got a replacement for it
i'm assuming i need another gun
boy, Daddy really got a good security mesurement for this one
aight, so i'm going upstairs, maybe not
maybe i changed my mind about that because i rememer there was a dog head riiiight here
there's 3, fuuck
at least i can put one
okay, goody goody gumdrops i did that!
anybody wanna tell how bad i am at that?
maybe i should put this back
no i can't, i can't even put  it back anymore
is this stuck constantly at 10.15
man i don't know what i'm doing with my gOd DAMN LIFE
hi grandma how you doing grandma *smooch*
mmhmhm love you
okay! let's get this thing
*gasp* it's a thing! i can make a thing out of this thing!
oh, that's good. any chem in here? i need to make some bullets
thank you for the bullets
any other chem?
what the fuck was that?
you gotta make weird ass noises behind me?
"It's a disgusting mess of god-knows-what"
I ALREADY TOLD YOU
I FOUND IT OUT
IT'S GRANDMAS ASHES
plenty of grandmas remains
for everybody to enjoy whenever they wanna take a bath-
HEY FUCKING
WOW HI. HOLY SHIT
NICE HEAD
Jack: Heck of a thing, ain't it?
Sure as shit beats the hell out of dying.
Mark: i s'pose. maybe, i don't know about that
woah, okay. alright then
Jack: My little girl has given us a gift
Mark: whoah is that the gift?
Jack: and this gift is with me always.
Mark: OKAY GOODBYE
I DON'T WANT THE GIFT. I DON'T WANT YOUR GIFT
Jack: As you can see, the family is only a part of her gift.
Mark: AAHAHAH FUUCK
whoah wha. no imnhmhn HA HE HEY okay goodbye
Jack: Which - in a word - means, you're fucked.
Mark: okay i don't know if i'm fucked about it
that's a bit cataclysmic don't you- aahh
Eeeuhueeeoh
okay it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine
it's fine. everything is fINE
i politely close my doors
and everything is good
ohh fuck
oh fuck, oh god, okay. everything is good, everything good
i'm a bRAavE bOooOyY
k, so i just need to make this into an eagle
like oohh in and SWOOP
swoop ya... swoop... swoop
YEAH i did it okay
did that open the door? yes, it did
man, this house as great architecture if there's just constantly things opening secretly
Ethan: Who builds this shit?
Mark: oh fuck
hello?
you coming after me?
i guess
yeah that's- that's exactly what i was wondering
who builds this shit like who took the time to build all of this stuff
who put this into an old Colonial house
in the middle of a bog in Louisiana. it just doesn't make a lot of sense
who built it. that's what got me thinking- ugh there's black goop over here ugh
but it may have something to do with the Umbrella Corporation
because the manor in the original "Resident Evil" was a-
god i didn't mean to do that. god! stop splashing yourself with Goop Juice
you're getting too much Goop everywhere!
conserve it! save it! save the Goop-oh hi.
You want some Goop? Ugh...
"lright then
Lemme just reload this one because i have a funny feeling that i
gonna NEEEEEEEEEED it
*slashes deer* YOU ALIVE? ...Better not be
Better not come alive, Bambi! Better not come aliive!!
*smashes box* Handgun Ammo, they give me a lot of-
Psychostimulants?!
Oh sure OMNOMNOMNOMNOM
Let me pop those in my ass
or-
face, what do I-the fuck that I said
Why do I need those?
"Use Psychostimulants to find items"
OOOOOH of course
OOOOOOH goooooood
You want me to do that now and they- *slam*
*whispering* the fuck was that?
eeegh...
*quietly* okay then
Orange manure, garlic
so lot of stuff in there and one bird-
oh that's two headed bird
*quietly* the fuck is that
oh what is that
woah HI
okay
that's so weird
but there's a gun in there
and there's probably a way to get to that gun
I think this is Daddy's drinking room
because there's a lot of beers that I know he likes to drink
go- and Daddy's shittin' throne
good, always good to know that he's got that at the ready
he never needs to leave this area
oh shit
it's Dad's plottin' room
oh boy
it's dad's tackle box
*quietly* ooh...
"you can't jimmy it open"
ok so I gotta find something for that
"Vacationing husband and wife--
the husband was a success,
he's the 12th.
Unfortunately the wife was no good,
so we'll just get rid of her
July 7th, three college girls. They're all rotten, Lucas is a damn idiot.
August 13th, homeless man.
turned in 3 days, he's the 13th.
Okay, so thi--this has to do with
that list that we found in the basement earlier in the last episode.
They were some sort of like--WOAH what the fuck is that
what the FUCK is THAAAAT
I see TEETH an' a MOUTH inside a MOUTH
A HEAD IN A MOUTH
some sort of horrible monstrosity, that's what that is
so I'm assuming that's what they're turning into
which is gonna be MONSTERS
so, they're doing some sort of experimentation
and I can only ASSUME
that is has SOMETHING to do
with a virus of some sort
because that's all what Resident Evil is all about
they LOVE them some
aaaaaaaAAAAAAAAGH
WHY DID I OPEN DAD'S TACKLE BOX
DAD'S BAIT BOX
euuugh, dad's baitn' box.
eugh.
Ok, so they--they must be doing some sort of experimentation
with these viruses,
THAT'S why the house
is so intricate and well-built.
"they all look like they might be victims"
and that's why these guys are taking meticulous notes,
and that's why--what the hell is this?
"looks like a kid drew it." So a kid drew a picture of Mia
surrounded by butterflies
well that's awfully nice but I--
I don't think that's gonna be WHOOOAAA
it's dad's *BLACK ROOM*
EEEUUUUGHHH
IEEUUUGHHH
EEEEUUUUITGHHH--
WHAT THE FUCKING FUCK
WHAT THE FUCK
*WHAT* THE FUCKING FUCK
DON EVEN TRY
HOLY FUCKING SH--OH MY *GAAWD!*
WHAT THE FUUUUUCK
*spooked markimoo*
erkay, alright...
you ok buddy? you okay?
oh god...
you gonna come back to life?
aw fucking shit!
so--*noise* (quietly) no--shh don't fuck with me
oh shit, oh fuck
so NOW this just got legit.
there's the family members
that I can't kill
but now there's actual monsters
that are gonna come POURING out of the fuckin WALLS
willy. nilly.
oh boy.
this is the opposite of good. ooh fuck.
don't you be makin noises on me
I do not like.
was there anything in here that I needed--
it doesn't seem like there was a lot of items in the past two rooms here
I've been trying to get everything I can scavenged
but I'm gonna run out of stuff eventually
yeesh
'specially if now I got things that need KILLIN'
yoi
least I know why
they're givin' me all these guns
if I can't kill the family members,
at least I can kill them
lemme uh,
mix me up some more bullets
can at least do that, boink
alright.
ha yeah that was probably the best use of it
because i got plenty of herbs, back in the box
so if i can just get more chem fluid,
ugh. AM I A BRAAAAVE BOYYYY
AAAAAAAAAAA
FUCK I HATE BASEMENTS
fuuck.
eeugh
why does is look like the walls are oozing blood?
that is the opposite of GOOOD! fuck oh fuck this shit.
oh fuck you gonna cOME OUT AT ME?
I see the outline of SOMEONE
ooh. do I?
maybe i don't.
eugh fuuuck
is that a spine? ooh god
fuck this place
oh, fuck this place
ooo
ooo fuck this place
FUCK YOU. YOU GONNA COME OUTTA THE WALL?
HUH?
YOU GONNA FIGHT THIS BRAVE BOY? HAAH?
fuck you and fuck you an fuck you an fuck you and fuck all of you oh, god
oh fuck this shit
what the fuck is that
oh, fuck you
(whispering) oh, fuck you
now I'm--WHAAAAT FUCKING FUCKING FUCK
JESUS CHRIST
oh my god, FUCK OFF
jeez, it had, it had a lot 'a teeth.
I saw, a lot of teeth.
out of nowhere.
I saw a lot of fucking teeth
fuck you dude
ewileugh
I don't have enough bullets to go on a deep excursion here
HOI FUCKIG WOAH
WOAH YOU'RE JUST STANDING THERE
HOLY FUCKING SHIT oh my god
okay so they're handleable
I can tolerate 'em
I just don't have a lot left.
Jesus Christ.
is there any more chem storage down here?
I'm startin' to see some m-more intricate things in this house
that shouldn't be in a normal house
with a normal family
seen a lot 'a really--oh fuck
*deep breath*
aw noh
yeesh--"Tamara"
"Shaun"
yeesh
"William"
okay
*sniffle*
this one's got a bloody hand--bl--print "Craig"
alright, fine Craig
cool Craig, Craig's cool
"Lara," nothing
"Travis."
It's locked!
Of course it's locked!
God there's so many things that are locked in this game
oh hello
"Lucas, I caught the guy who keeps trying to escape.
I've locked him in the leftmost incinerator
so he can't get away again.
Take him out when he's ready.
You know how to open the door, don't you?
Just remember, three "A's" and a handprint.
Do what you want with his girl."
Oh, god
eeeugh
"three A's and a handprint"
the fuck does that mean?
"three A's and a handprint" so there's gotta be some other locking mechanism
that can get that open
but I just don't know if that's in this room
haa fuck
I just wanna get back and save
"Workshop"
that sounds fun
"it's locked from the other side" auggghh of course it is FUCK
alright then
what else we got
hello? oh this looks bad
oh god
eugh
eeeuuUGHAAAAAAAAAAA
EEEEUUUUUUUAAAAAAA
fuck. alright. UH I'm gonna back out
yanno I'm just gonna bail
I'm gonna bail on that one
bailarino fuck thisis bad
eyup ok imma get that with my strong hand
(softly but with feeling) fuck
okay. who wants some?
ooh fuck.
anybody want some? huh?
I gotta whole lotta "some"
if anybody wants it
"Processing Area Map"
Jesus, processing what?
They're givin' me a lot of ammo and health, which usually is a bad sign
shit
's that a thing?
oh there's an herb there
almost missed that
*deep sigh* oh boy
"you've unlocked it" what did I unlock?
heeeuy
*squishing & squelching noises*
the fuck was that?
whaddid I unlock?
is this the way back?
eeeugh
oh it is!
okay, alright maybe I can just get to the save point that'd be great
that'd be fuckin' great
fuck that basement. Jesus.
I don't need that in my life.
ooh. OOOOOOOH IT'S A SAVE ROOM
OH I DIDN'T HAVE TO GO DOWN THERE
OH I COULDA COME IN HERE
had a nice fun, relaxing time
ugh ok. Anyway
I'm all out of time for this episode here
*tk* UUUUUUUUUGH
I do not like that basement
but I'm a brrraave boy and I'm gonna go down there
so THANK you everybody so much for watching
I hope you're enjoying this series
because I absolutely am *outro music starts*
so lemme know what you think in the comments down below
and as always, I will see you in the next video
Buh-bye!